one of the kryptonites of the American
social media General culture is that
there are people who can say this person
is bad and you should never speak to
them you should never have them on your
platform and that can have a Rippling
effect I mean maybe it's a non discount
but maybe it's just someone who posts
under their real name the ADL which has
its own political bias doesn't like them
well if you're banned from Twitter what
stops you from being banned from PayPal
PayPal from MailChimp from all of these
other organizations that say well we
heard that you were bad we heard that
you're not we're not allowed to support
you I mean there is a really serious
ripple effect that damages free speech
in this culture and the ADL has been at
the center of it for a long time
I love the idea that the ADL
Anti-Defamation League could get sued
for defamation yeah so people are
calling them the defamation leave yep
but they've been sued I guess for
defamation before 20 some odd years ago
they had to pay a fine I don't know
exactly what happened with that but this
is a key component to the narrative
manipulation in this country
organizations like the ADL and the splc
lie lie lie lie lie lie all the time